is that
the jcvi
the joint committee on vaccination and
immunization
is
not recommending
covid vaccines for healthy children
between the ages of 12 and 15. that
breaking news just into us let's explore
this more uh with our correspondent ali
fortescue who is in the newsroom and um
just a short time ago we were talking
weren't we to professor jeremy brown and
very very cagey on that specific issue
we perhaps now know why
yeah absolutely i mean i think this has
come as quite a surprise because as you
say just a few moments ago we were
talking to professor jeremy brown who
was telling us that there had not yet
been a decision reached and wasn't
telling us exactly um whether or not we
we were going to find out soon whether
children between the ages of 12 and 15
were to be vaccinated we know of course
at the vaccine rollout the first doses
have been expanded to children who are
16 years old but there was plenty of
speculation about where the school-aged
children were going to get that vaccine
too and we know
there's been an open letter written
today from parents unions scientists
including scientists from the
independent sage group
urging younger children the government
to look at vaccinating younger children
so they can be better protected of
course that is a big tranche of society
children that are now back at school
mixing
so i think there had been many who had
expected the rollout to be expanded to
those younger age groups but we now have
confirmation
that the vaccine is not being
recommended by the government's vaccine
advisors for children aged between 12
and 15. but
they do go on to say that the program is
being extended from what they'd
been considered most at risk children to
include children
who also have chronic major heart
illnesses lung kidney liver and
neurological conditions so that means
that about 200 000 more children are
going to be invited for vaccines but the
breaking news this afternoon is that
children age between 12 and 15 years old
are not being recommended by the
government's vaccine advisors to receive
the covid19 jab yes indeed ali and we've
got some words coming out now from the
jcvi uh that says benefits are
insufficient to support uh this mass
vaccination for 12 to 15 year olds but
those with underlying health conditions
will get it so certainly not across the
board and as you say there's something
of a surprise so um
all these details are coming out now
it's just very interesting wasn't it we
didn't know how to read professor jeremy
brown when we were talking to him when
he was talking specifically i asked him
about 12 to 15 year olds i hardly said
anything on it but the other thrust of
what we were talking about was this
booster
um suggestions even as early as next
monday uh that they might be introduced
but that's not going to happen because
the jcvi haven't signed off and he said
ideally there is actually no rush to do
that
yeah that's right it was really
interesting actually listening to what
he was saying about booster vaccines
we've heard the prime minister
confirming really that that will be
happening uh from september but he again
wouldn't be drawn on that and crucially
he did say that there is no evidence yet
that the protection that the vaccines
are offering to people has faded yet so
he suggested that we did still have some
time but he did say that the protection
would fade more quickly and elderly
people we know of course that half a
million of the most clinically
vulnerable have been told that they need
to come and get a third dose of the
covered vaccine and i think we are now
seeing a refocus on when people will be
getting those booster vaccines um
some people looking to israel and the
rising cases they're suggesting that
that is that is a sign that we need to
be thinking very soon about booster
vaccines but he
wouldn't really been be drawn on
specific dates and he did say that they
they wouldn't um fall prey to
ministerial pressure but i think as you
say the most important thing this
afternoon really is the news now that
those younger age groups for children
aged between 12 and 15 will will not be
receiving their doses of the kova
vaccine